have you ever looked around and wondered
where does all of my stuff come from
maybe you have a pencil that looks
something
like
this
now lots of different things go into
making a pencil but we can break it down
into a few basic parts
for example the wood that makes up the
body of the pencil comes from trees
most pencil erasers nowadays are made
from some kind of plastic which is
refined from oil and this aluminum ring
here at the base of the pencil and the
graphite tip at the top are both made
from different minerals
everything we use can be traced back to
natural
resources
which are things provided by the earth
and its processes
some natural resources that we use a lot
in our day-to-day lives are trees
fresh water
minerals
and fossil fuels like oil
we can divide these different types of
natural resources into renewable
resources
and
non-renewable resources
renewable resources can be replenished
in a relatively short amount of time
now i say relatively short because in
some cases it still might take quite a
few years for them to renew
for example if you have a tree
and you cut it down but you plan a new
tree to take its place
you're still going to have to wait let's
say 20 years before you can have another
fully grown tree
non-renewable resources are often very
limited and can take much longer than a
human lifetime for the earth to
replenish them
for example when carbon is compressed
for millions of years it can turn into a
diamond
once we mine that diamond out of the
earth it'll take millions of years for
another diamond to be formed that's the
same size
now just because a resource is renewable
doesn't mean we can use as much as we
want whenever we want
we know that trees are a renewable
resource right
however cutting down too many trees a
process called deforestation can have
downsides many animals rely on trees for
habitat or food and they can't exactly
wait 20 years for their homes to grow
back
plus taking wood out of the ecosystem
and burning it releases extra carbon
dioxide that's going to end up in the
atmosphere rather than naturally moving
through the carbon cycle this is one of
many things that contributes to climate
change
we also can't find all the natural
resources we need and all of the places
where we need them different places have
unique geographic or geologic features
like mountains and forests or rivers and
oceans
so they all have different resources
since natural resources aren't evenly
distributed different regions trade sell
or exchange their resources with each
other
for example let's say a community lives
at the base of these mountains here so
they can chop down wood from the forest
whenever they need it
if they go looking in the mountains they
might even find some rare minerals
another community down the road lives
near the river so they can go fishing
every day the soil near the river is
also really good for growing crops so
they farm a lot of tasty vegetables
now let's say the people in the mountain
community want to eat the fish pumpkins
and other crops harvested in the river
community
at the same time the river community
wants those hard to find minerals and
wood to make new farm tools
they'll need to find a way to share
their unique resources so everyone gets
what they need
now try and imagine this system on a
global scale
the things we rely on every day from the
pencils that you use to write to the
technologies that power our communities
they all connect us in some way back to
the resources that our planet naturally
provides
take a look around again
where in the world did the things in
your life really come from once you
break an object down to its original
pieces you might be surprised by what
you find